Sweden's largest internet service  provider is located somewhere you might  not expect below 100 feet of bedrock in  a former nuclear bunker the peon and  data center houses some of the most  sensitive information in the world which  once included WikiLeaks servers they can  help protect their clients information  under Sweden's free speech Act inside  engines intended to be for German  submarines are used as backup generators  the design and style is the work of CEO  John Carlin who took inspiration from  his love of film he says that the choice  to put plants in the cave was to capture  the computer meets plants vibe of sci-fi  films from the 70 the plans are kept  alive by grow lights the center has  simulated daylight and the waterfall  well that's just for fun and while it  may look like a villains lair from James  Bond you won't find Goldfinger here just  the 15 senior technical staff who run  the servers  [Music]  you  [Music]